ago like you remember I was talking I
I'll give you a quick update because
it's not the thing I want to trade hey
you recommend me Chuck Francis to start
dating yeah and I tell you about the
coach and you didn't recommend me to do
that but I trust myself and I go for it
and now I know how to approach yours and
I feel more confidence a lot
okay so what's your question tonight
the first thing is that I've been
unplugged by you in a long time ago then
by Robert hyosaki then by a lot of young
entrepreneurs but lastly recently I got
unplugged by Luke Belmar about a lot of
likes from society like how you should a
Mali thing is something is expensive uh
or cheap based on your time and resource
uh the world economic Forum that is a
lie lies about
the war they say the second war I have
to question that but
um there are it's a lot of information
and I is
how to continue my life like after today
well you put over here in the chat in
the private chat that you have an ex
existential crisis around all this new
information
Welcome to the Real World
how old are you hey it's sunny
20. so you're a young man and you live
in Argentina
but the thing is I'm thinking about
taking a step back because I'm I'm in
college I was getting into
entrepreneurship okay but these things I
started to question myself why because I
was planning a lot but not doing things
and I would plan and write it and looked
look well you just that you're just
scratching the surface of what of what
the world's really like so
the follow-up to all of this now that
you've okay you've checked all these
things out you know you you're starting
to unplug from The Matrix is you know we
like to call it
now it's asking more questions it's like
why why why do we do it that way why is
it that they would want me to do it that
way why does the government want me to
do this why does my whatever want things
done that way right it's just asking why
it's why why why why
right and and then that follow-up
question after that is okay well how
does this serve me how does this align
with the kind of man that I want to
become
right if yes you know if if if family or
your church for example says something
like you need to marry that girl over
there and you're going to have children
with her and you need to do it right now
in the next six months and you look at
her and she's completely not your type
and it just encased in religious
Cultural Family Values you'd be like
okay why I don't need to do that I have
other plans I have bigger plans right or
they tell you to go get the government
job why I have other plans I have bigger
plans I'm going to be an entrepreneur
I'm going to look at you know to solve
bigger problems and things that I'm
interested in you don't have to do
what people culture Society government
everybody tells you to do that's just
what you're figuring out now and you
don't need my permission some Canadian
guy 7 000 miles away on the other side
of the Equator telling you you know what
you can and can't do it's just taking
ownership now for all of these thoughts
and Views and opinions that you're
starting to develop about the way the
world really works and what people
really respond to and what women really
are about and how businesses really
transacted and how the rich people
actually make money you know next week's
show is going to be about how to make
money I'll talk about that next week
right but you get what I'm saying it's
just it's just you don't have an
existential crisis you've just unplugged
from some lies and now it's time for you
to start looking around and you know
looking for better ways of doing things
now it's just applying it to life but
the thing is that I implied and let's
say after this change are you thinking
about my old self and My New Self and
it's something like you read the
personal by record Solly yeah
well I'm looking something like that
like the old self versus the new self
who's taking control of my mind and
because everybody's gonna push back man
your family's gonna push back your
friends will push back people will push
back they're gonna say oh you can't do
it that way that's not right or yeah
so what but I'm I'm listening to my to
my God like what do I use would you
would you rather trade places with a guy
like Robert Kiyosaki and live his life
or trade places with a guy that's
telling you not to do what Kiyosaki did
for example
100 yeah so don't take advice from
people that you wouldn't trade lives
with
yeah but that's that's not the the real
I that's part of the question but the
question is I don't know when I'm
thinking if I'm thinking with the old
self or the new self because I want to
stop a university stop entrepreneurship
and find my inner self because there's
something I'm doubting and I think once
I saw that I can't Define goals I think
something planning and executing yeah I
think some of it's getting Lost in
Translation in your and you're running
ahead of yourself a little bit here you
don't have to completely change
everything that you do
right very new to all of this
I remember you called called in a couple
months ago or in you know recent past
talking about pickup and stuff like that
and and girls and that's when we talked
about francis's uh material but
take it easy man
take it easy you don't have to go and
leave you don't have to you know tell
your parents to pound sand or call them
peasants like okay
you know the fact that you call your
parents peasants in the private chat
here is somewhat concerning they may not
be as unplugged as you have become
but they may not necessarily be peasants
either they're still your parents right
okay they still have Goodwill for you
they still want what's best for you it's
just they only think about
what they know and you know the beliefs
that they've operated within which are
of course going to be limiting because
you find them limiting now and that's
fine yeah but if you can you know but if
you can do what it is that you hope to
do and you can one day you know buy them
a house or buy them a car or pay off
their mortgage they're never going to
bother you again
that's one of my my dreams so that I I
work so work towards doing that and
being that guy is what I'm saying you
know just and it doesn't have to happen
overnight you know just take a look
around ask questions maybe if you're in
a program in University that's not
aligned with where you want to go you
might want to change the program maybe
it's worthwhile not doing the program
and going to do something else and
finding a mentor there's different ways
that you can do it
no I think I'm in the right path of
finance and Entrepreneurship but it's
something that it doesn't lock in and I
want to look for that thing that it
doesn't like uh put the pieces together
well I'll tell you this my friend when
it
when it comes to you it'll be like
taking a frying pan to the forehead it's
going to be like taking a whack to the
forehead and you'll know it when it hits
you
it's already happening yeah yeah all
right man thanks for watching it thanks
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out